pierre départ bonsoir d'abord nouveau
PDG par intérim chez au Québec vraiment
un moment idéal pour faire votre entrée
en scène comme grand patron Diderot
de commencer il y a des baptêmes de feu
moi j'ai eu un baptême de glace puis
bonsoir Monsieur roi bonsoir alors
bienvenue sur le plateau je vais vous
montrer les derniers chiffres on est
vous les connaissez mais au bénéfice des
gens à
8447 pour tout le Québec ça s'apprécie
jour le chiffre paraît petit puisqu'on a
frôlé le million 1 mais quand même
au-dessus du milieu au dessus du milieu
mais pour ces gens-là six jours c'est
pas acceptable quelque chose qui ne
marche pas mais comment vous comment on
peut expliquer ça il faut comprendre
l'importance de l'événement c'est
l'événement on a eu un point un million
100000 clients avec perte de courant
qu'on a raccordé le plus rapidement
possible on a des grilles de priorité
pour raccorder les clients et on a
travaillé sur les pannes qui le plus de
clients qui étaient en interruption de
service on a été en mesure de raccorder
de rebrancher 80% des clients en
l'espace de deux jours de travail on a
on est rendu à la toute fin
effectivement ça peut paraître long mais
là on est vraiment dans les pannes qui
sont complexes qui sont difficiles
d'accès où il y a eu beaucoup de
dommages causés par la végétation et les
pannes qui a vraiment des particularités
puis qui sont plus longs je dois vous
dire qu'aujourd'hui au moment où on se
parle toutes les pannes liées au verglas
ont été adressées il y a des équipes qui
travaillent dessus donc ce qui prend
plus de temps c'est causé par la
complexité de la panne soit pour les
accès et pour rétablir le courant
monsieur Tellier je lui posais la
question votre collègue tout à l'heure
est-ce que on a assez de moteurs de
lignes dans la région de montré est-ce
que il y a eu assez de moteurs de lignes
de manière générale pour faire face à la
crise de ces jours la réponse est oui et
on avait accès aux équipes ailleurs en
région
on a amené à Montréal et on avait 1600
employés monteurs de ligne donc à peu
près 800 équipes qui travaillaient à
travailler durant toute la période du
coeur du congé pascal pour rétablir le
courant on n'a pas fait venir des gens
de l'exemple du Nouveau-Brunswick parce
que le travail était très spécifique sur
le réseau de distribution du
raccordement ok on avait beaucoup de
coordination à faire et donc dans
d'autres situations exemple sauf s'il y
avait eu des enjeux sur le réseau de
transmission ou des poteaux à remonter
où l'on aurait pu faire venir des
équipes additionnelles pour préparer le
terrain le travail pour permettre le
raccordement par nos équipes
d'Hydro-Québec donc on avait
suffisamment de musique
en même temps il y a un post mortem qui
va se faire chez Hydro-Québec est-ce
qu'on peut s'entendre ensemble que six
jours c'est trop long il faut trouver
des façons de faire pour que des clients
parce que là il faisait chaud mais c'est
pas trop froid disons ça comme ça mais
ça avait été en janvier c'est différent
pour trouver des façons de faire pour
raccorder plus vite ce que c'est
possible de vous en fait il va y avoir
un poste mortem où on va regarder les
différentes facettes de l'intervention
qui a eu lieu en fait semaine donc les
équipes la gestion des équipes la
communication avec le ministre le monde
municipal et le gouvernement donc on va
adresser chacune des facettes de
l'intervention pour voir comment on peut
améliorer l'intervention pour qu'elle
soit plus efficace plus rapide vous
comme moi l'objectif c'est de raccorder
les clients le plus rapidement possible
j'arrive en poste on va faire un post
mortem puis on rétablir un plan d'action
qu'on va utiliser pour un prochain
événement est-ce que il y a moyen puis
c'est revenu beaucoup vous l'avez
peut-être entendu cette jeune femme
arrosement qui dit j'étais dans le noir
où le monsieur qui dit vous aurez
peut-être pu venir me donner est-ce
qu'on peut mieux communiquer aux clients
vous savez qu'en temps normal lorsqu'il
y a des pannes on utilise l'application
info panne on indique la panne et
lorsqu'on a fait un excusez-moi une
vérification de la nature de la part on
donne un indication du délai de
raccordement pour donner justement cette
information là le plus précise au client
par le contexte où on avait au-dessus
d'un million de clients qui étaient en
panne ça devenait extrêmement difficile
c'était impossible à faire donc c'est
dans ce contexte particulier qu'il faut
comprendre qu'on était pas en mesure de
le faire depuis quelques temps ce
fibreushing nous en parlait nous en a
parlé plusieurs reprises on dit on va
mettre les bouchées doubles pour la
végétation le contrôle est végétation a
mieux que les arbres soient émondées etc
là est-ce que les bouchées doubles
devraient pas être cadruple et
quintuplées ça fait partie de ce qu'on
va faire dans le post mortem dans le
post-martin on va regarder à ce que
notre plan de végétation est adéquat
est-ce qu'on doit l'augmenter est-ce
qu'on doit le faire différemment on va
aussi se poser la question on
présentement on fait de l'enfouissement
de câble année première année à hauteur
d'environ 275 millions de dollars ok
est-ce qu'on devrait en faire plus
est-ce qu'on devrait à quel endroit on
devrait en faire donc on va vraiment
adresser les préoccupations qui
ressortent de l'événement connu pour
apprendre et être meilleur pour la
prochaine fois mais il se préparait pour
être plus efficace vous entendez
j'imagine que moi passer ou sur les
réseaux sociaux des commentaires des
gens disent est-ce qu'on peut être
remboursé est-ce qu'on peut avoir un
dédommagement est-ce que hydro-Québec a
une réflexion là dessus après six jours
quelqu'un qui a toujours pas de courant
par exemple en fait il y a pas de
réflexion à ce moment-ci sur l'aspect de
dédommagement donc paieront pas parce
qu'on peut être servi mais il y aura pas
plus que ça
mais il devrait pas avoir ce genre de
réflexion là quand si ça parce que je
vous montre le tableau le nombre la
durée moyenne des pannes en minutes
depuis 9 ans ça s'améliore Paul c'est ça
va de plus en plus c'est de plus en plus
long en moyenne est-ce que ça
il faut rétablir ça d'une façon d'une
autre il faut le rétablir ça c'était en
fait probablement vous l'avez pris du
rapport de la vérification générale du
Québec qui a fait un constat c'est
factuel il y a plus de panne les
panneaux évalué en nombre et en durée en
durée pour permettre le raccordement des
clients moi je prends acte du rapport on
va la regarder on est en train de
préparer notre plan d'action et répondre
à la vérification générale du Québec
avec l'objectif de diminuer le nom et de
raccorder plus rapidement après une
panne
très bien par ailleurs je le disais vous
arrivez en poste intérimaire qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire pour le les gens qui
nous écoutent est-ce que vous vous
sentez les mêmes coups de franges que si
vous étiez pas intérimaire est-ce que
c'est une pause est-ce que parce que
monsieur Legault on l'a vu est
impatientable des barrages on a parlé
que vos collègues comment vous voyez
votre nouveau mandat en fait moi pour la
petite histoire je suis sorti de ma
retraite en 2020 pour venir travailler
chez Hydro-Québec et donc donner un coup
de main servir le Québec à travers au
Québec j'aime beaucoup l'organisation
j'ai travaillé à la réalisation du plan
stratégique et lorsque le conseil
d'administration m'a demandé si j'étais
prêt à prendre l'intérim du PDG dans le
contexte où le PDG aurait pas été nommé
j'ai trouvé ça très flatteur de leur
part et j'ai été honoré et j'ai dit oui
donc il y a beaucoup de choses à faire
on a un plan stratégique qui est en
place on était en première année de
réalisation ce plan là
on veut continuer à travailler puis dans
mon intérim on va continuer à travailler
sur la réalisation du plan stratégique
voulez-vous la job à temps plein j'ai
été très flatté qu'on me demande de
faire l'intérêt si on me demande si je
suis intéressé et je vais songer c'est
très sérieusement les projets de barrage
ce qu'on doit comprendre puis on avait
une interview il y a la semaine dernière
avec un de vos collègue petit mécati
nain par exemple est-ce qu'on doit
comprendre que on va accélérer le tempo
dans les études et que c'est possible
que dans 12 13 15 ans et un barrage là
mais ce qu'on va faire il faut
comprendre le contexte dans lequel on
est il y a une augmentation de la
demande qui est anticipée et on a géré
une offre qui est somme toute qui va
réduire dans le temps donc il faut
regarder par quels moyens on va être
capable d'augmenter l'offre pour
répondre à la demande croissance
croissant dans le futur on l'a vu on a
parlé de santé donc ce qu'on doit
regarder aujourd'hui c'est quels sont
les moyens à notre disposition pour
augmenter l'offre énergétique c'est dans
un premier temps on a annoncé 1500
mégawatts de d'éoliens ont dans notre la
stratégie qu'on parle de 3000 mégawatts
d'éolien la semaine dernière aussi on a
annoncé en même temps qu'on parlait de
petits mercatinat on a annoncé qu'on ne
voulait doubler nos objectifs
d'efficacité énergétique l'efficacité
énergétique va faire va rendre
disponible des électrons pour adresser
la demande et dans le code petit était
Catinat ce qu'on a dit c'est qu'on est
en analyse préliminaire on doit aller
voir le terrain on va communiquer avec
les parties prenantes donc les
communautés
les résidents pour vraiment déterminer
si le projet peut être intéressant à
quelles conditions et après ça plus tard
prendre la décision mais si on n'est pas
une décision aujourd'hui non pas
aujourd'hui mais il prend en avoir une
d'ici 6 mois c'est plus que 6 mois une
étude préliminaire c'est si on parle
d'un horizon 2 ans deux ans donc d'ici
presque la fin du mois d'août monsieur
Legault il ne sera pas si voir un
barrage là ou pas en fait on va faire
les travaux on va voir comment les
travaux avancent puis on pourra poser un
jugement au fur et à mesure qu'on va
avancer mais pas avant 2 ans
j'arrive aujourd'hui les gens
je le dise pas de votre faute si le
karma fait que vous arrivez vous en
pleine panne mais voilà très bien merci
beaucoup on va se reparler donc pierre
départ PDG par intérim chez droit-québec
merci beaucoup